okay
we're back on good so um so we'll now go
open to debate discussion and we need to
come to a conclusion
um so who wants to go first
cancer passed more
oh i thought sorry i thought that's if
not i've got another hand i thought
that's where you were i i i will i will
say something um
so
clearly just the reserve matters here
and i do think we need to make a
decision
and i do think we need to move on and
make that decision so
having listened carefully i think the
applicants have made considerable
adjustments and in my view i think they
have
more or less done enough for me to
support this application but i am
concerned about this issue about the
parking and highways and i wonder if
there are other conditions we can add
if we were to give approval particularly
looking at the play area and the parking
so there's some negotiation that you can
come together it's very difficult to
come up with a precise solution but i
think from when we've met before and
other applications there is a
willingness to talk to the planning
authority and local people to come up
with a solution in spite of what
his or her lordship the inspectors have
said because it sounds to me chairman
there was a willingness to reach
agreement with local people which is
really really important
so if that could be conditioned i would
be happy to propose it on the basis
we've got that with that with that
exception
i don't quite know how we do it though
case office sounds good very quickly so
let's go to bradley then gemma
thank you chair yeah um just on the
point of the play area i understand
exactly the points being made with that
um
all i would say is that i don't want to
over emphasize it but there is an
indicative plan that is expected to be
generally caught in in general
accordance and i think the other thing
to bear in mind that the land north
has got out on planning permission so
that would have a centralized location
in the future
and i accept it is in the future but
that potentially then could be addressed
by development on that side so i i
accept what you're saying counselor in
terms of its location at this point the
other thing i'd say about the access is
that that has got full planning
permission right um so if there were any
works to be proposed in the highway i
presume and i don't know what ian's got
a view on this but it'd have to be done
under the highways act
um to prevent parking or whatever or do
do something in relation to parking
because it would be out with the um
the site it would be actually in highway
i think bradley covered the points i was
going to raise thank you perfect
okay
yeah
yeah i mean i i yeah i tend to agree
that by and large we've got the um
we've got about as
the best we can manage to persuade the
applicant to give us
um one little thing about the parking
exactly again
um
i don't know what the
intentions are
along that around that corner of the of
the um
of the drainage um basin occasional
drainage basin um i i can see informal
parking breaking out there actually um
unless it's actually not possible
um now whether that we might think
that's actually desirable
um
and um
and let it happen anyway but um
i think just just to to sort of make
that point that um
you know given the proximity of the shop
and everything and people's um
uh what should i say their desire lines
from their car door to the shop door
um just pointing at that corner um
things might happen
i agree that people at the moment people
park pretty much opposite there don't
they from time to time
um
yeah tricky
councilman
uh thank you chair um
you know i i i i commend the um
applicant for doing some community
involvement i mean so often we're here
when we hit we hear that there hasn't
been any at all so i i would like to say
thank you very much for doing that and
it does appear that you have um listened
to some extent
but yeah
i still i'm still not convinced that
this is the best layout that we could
fit in this particular development
i realize there are limitations
i i'm a bit of a skeptic about the
non-adopted roads i'm sorry i don't
really understand the system properly
the the play area doesn't appear to be
in a in a sort of central well
overlooked uh area
um
we've got the electric boilers
um which we seem to have to accept okay
it's not gas there's no gas in the area
anyway
um
but you know
is that the best thing all of these sort
of initiatives are all well and good
about saying oh yeah it's going to be a
renewable tariff but the energy still
got to come from somewhere
and it's going to be
polluting somewhere else even if it's
not not actually here in backton um
i mean
on the face of it i think yes maybe it
is the the best we're going to get but
but should we be satisfied with with a
compromise um
i i really don't know um
so i'm uh i'm i'm pondering in my mind
which way i'm gonna gonna
sit i'm not entirely happy
but maybe this is what we're going to
have to live with
thanks councillor e burn then councillor
field
um thank you chair i'm slightly of the
same mind you know there's a few
you know and i appreciate the appeal
decision and what the inspector said and
so on so forth
i am
concerned about the
you know i know that area very well the
parking by the
shop green will be an utter nightmare
with that estate road coming out onto it
unless there's really good um
enforced restrictions or some agreement
with the shop that people can use the
visitor car park in this state or
whatever because people park actually
all around the corners um and it's
yeah accidents waiting to happen
so if anything can be done there that i
think as people have said already
the
i am very concerned about the footpath
going out onto church road and i think
there just has to be some kind of
bollard or some kind of restriction to
you know reinforce the fact that you
can't just cycle straight out onto that
bit of road
um and i appreciate that the
other um
[Music]
development's going to come forward
next the site so that play area you know
will be next to other houses but i'm not
really happy about that and i think it
would have just been a nicer development
if you've had that in the middle
especially given the fact that land
that
effectively through the appeal decision
was put aside for open space is now
becoming attenuation bonds so
again if there was something they could
do about this
and finally um
there's an awful lot of applications in
bacton and an awful lot of construction
happening or about happening back to nan
hawley so can
on any condition can the construction
management plan be really clear as to
where hgvs are going and preferably not
over the humpback bridge into hawley not
under they won't fit anyway the um
the low bridge um north of backton so
can that
construction plan be extremely clear
as to what's going to happen there thank
you
thanks councillor field
thank you i feel
we are constrained by the inspector and
the layout and i don't honestly see it
so it's a poor layout it seems quite
acceptable
uh parking issues are always a problem
uh in fact that mayhem is really as bad
as
we or local people predict
it's
usually people do manage to cope with
these things acceptably
i have to say that if you sort of get to
the pretty trivial or not that much of
an enthusiast for artificial chimneys
he seems a bit embellishment that make
the roof less structurally sound for
no good purpose whatsoever
but i guess that's a small thing to
tolerate
i am concerned about the electric
heating i didn't hear that the houses
were higher than normal insulation
standards
i can guess pretty much they aren't
and
electric heating without the benefit of
night storage
which cuts the price perhaps two to one
or heat pumps which cuts the running
costs by
three to one
it sounds like an awfully expensive
option for
some other residents
so
i find i'm largely in agreement
with this with perhaps those uh
one minor point and one that i think is
a significant ongoing cost for
the
future occupants
i leave it there for the moment
thanks okay well i guess it's up to you
up to me to have a view now as we've
been around the room um so so um
i mean the inspector has made a decision
uh and this has come forward uh we've
heard around the reasonings for the
player where it is and we've heard it's
part of a bigger picture so
i'm not that upset by where the player
is located because of the big picture in
terms of the parking being estate owned
and actually that means that people
probably will be far more on top of
making sure it does work
because they have direct ownership and
responsibility for it you know
i've lived in a block of flats where
everyone was on the management committee
and i assure you you know people
wouldn't let anything go wrong so i
think it's the same sort of thing
whereas if it's highways it's far more
difficult for them to have a say so i
would think that they've got that
opportunity to manage it
in terms of um the electric heating well
of course we'd rather move away from
that but it's just not quite there yet
and we can't stop development until
we're absolutely at that point of where
things will change
you know across the whole of the
building industry it's getting there
we're nearly there so i think the
electric i can live with the electric
heating
um but it's a good point about this the
the
tariff and the timing and whether it's
night storage or not because that does
make a huge difference to the running of
the bills
in terms of the attenuation ponds yeah
they've got to go somewhere i i think
i'd rather have them there than right at
the back because at least when you enter
you
i think that sort of adds
adds to it
um so it's not 100 perfect it could be
probably tweaked but actually overall i
can live with it so i will be supporting
in fact as no one else has made a
proposal i'm happy to propose
um support sorry
oh did you oh i missed that sir
okay well i'm happy to second it then um
second the recommendation
yes um with with the caveat there were
discussions locally about
resolving the parking matter whether you
do that through an advisory note or a
formal condition so on it's in interest
of everybody to come up with a solution
involving highways what is this what is
the the the
problem you want to be addressed it's on
it's on the road on why versus the road
particularly not not so much within the
estate
because um highways correspond to what i
can see here
i'm not sure they've really addressed
that and i think it would be in
everybody's interest
even at this stage to make sure we can
see if there is a practical solution i
don't want to make a mountain out of a
molehill on this but i think it is an
issue i think john was saying people
will tend to fit in i get that but if
there was a way just to try and tidy
that up i think that would be suitable
so i'm happy with an advisory note for
that or something but um
um i think the issue i've got is that
the access is outside of this
application we are restricted to
landscaping appearance scale and layout
so that would be a concern i think
you've got the developer in the room and
i would say that they're here and
listening and that an informative is not
going to really do anything else so i
would suggest
that's something we struggle with to do
anything further on planning but i'm
sure they're here and listening for you
could i just check on the recommendation
i think councilory burn suggest sorry it
might be canceled so somebody suggested
a barrier to the cycle link on church
road was that something you wanted to
add as a condition thank you cancer
event
or not as proposer and seconder
happy to include that
thank you
yeah just just to ask
in these settlements
um where there are multiple
um applications in in in train
um as as the case here in baton with
with what three five five is it
um
i think it is immensely helpful to to
actually have a a plan that shows
the other applications in the area i
think you know
i'm not clear where the the new school
and the houses to the north might be
going but that might have actually given
us greater comfort on the location of
that play area
if we'd known how it was fitting
together but it's not there today
that's a good point actually we normally
do have a dumpling that shows all the
different things in the era so yeah good
point
yeah councilman could i just check
the the the recommendation on page 533
which i'm assuming is the one we're
working to um
often we have great long reams of
conditions
i just want to check that that we have
covered everything that we normally
cover in a reserved matters application
um because it seems quite short this
time i'm sorry i haven't checked up all
the old ones but often we have much more
gemma
absolutely i mean perhaps might ship in
here as well but essentially the
inspector did condition a fair amount of
things he constructed a construction
management plan sustainability measures
amongst other things so a lot of the
things we would normally be concerned
about have been covered at that stage
and i think then brothers will somewhat
probably summarize the others so it
doesn't look quite as long as we might
normally expect that that's spot on it's
just um we can't repeat the ones he's
already imposed so
elements are important are already
covered by the outline conditions we
feel so um that that lesser list
reflects the reserve matters nature
and the conditions they've already got
to comply with
thank you for that i'm all for
summarizing things because it means i've
got less to read so i like things to be
succinct and summarized um can i just
check that the uh we've got the
ecological mitigation in accordance with
the ecological appraisal recommendations
uh does that include you know sort of
wildlife corridors and hedgehog fencing
and
and the like that is that all included
in that it does
yeah that that would be covered by that
yeah
okay so i think on that basis we'll go
to a vote please
so claire it was the recommendation on
533 with the extra condition is that
okay with you
okay thank you members
that vote is now in progress you may
need to scroll down slightly to see the
vote
um
the wording is that the application be
approved as detailed in the office of
recommendation with the inclusion the
recommend that should be on page five
through three with the inclusion of the
officer's further recommendation
but
i think we're i think we all know what
that is saying
are you happy with that ian yes it is
yeah
am i allowed to ask the applicant now
we've done the boat well hold on
okay
thank you members that's fine
that's five votes four and one against
okay yes of course john
that was to change anything i just
wondered whether he actually has an
estimate for the annual running cost of
a
one of the middle sized houses
you know given the usual number of
degree days that you get in a year and
the uh
known cost of electricity
um so i haven't got a figure in terms of
pound notes but what we did we have done
fabric first as well so the point you
made about installation we've increased
the insulation so what i can tell you is
in terms of the these houses will use 47
less energy than with normal what
building regulations at the moment
requires so so we're using much less
energy
and using things like the wastewater
heat recovery and the pv to keep those
running costs down
thank you should have said that before
okay well thanks very much thank you for
joining us yes so we've got literally
five minute break to clean the seats and
then we're only going to get one more
application in today looking at the
clock which will be the
the next application in backton
okay welcome back so uh the next
application before us today is uh
dc20572 the bungalow church road backton
and hand over to the case officer over
to you
thank you chad um this application has
been before members previously
it was deferred at that point for
further information to be sought with
regards to two trees that have been
removed from site
just to make members aware since that
time we have had an appeal against
non-determination of the application
coming as well
so any decision that is made today
doesn't determine the application that
sits with the planning inspectorate but
it would give
officers reasons to defend at the appeal
if that was the
decision of members
we've had um
late papers circulated
and there's nothing further
subject to the late papers and the
report in front of members
so this is the wider
aerial map of bacton um
it's development on a site
and we can see part of the 81 unit site
off to the west there
it's part of a site that previously
received outline planning permission for
the development of three houses and the
retention of the existing bungalow on
site
this application is full application
so it's not tied to the the outliner
when not looking at a reserve matters
this application seeks
the erection of one new dwelling on the
site and it also seeks to create second
access onto church roads
you can see their members that we've got
um were within the built up area
boundary of backed in for the purposes
of the 1998 local plan um
the emergent joined local plan retains
the site um within the settlement
boundary and then we've got the list of
buildings that we were discussing
previously
we've got the manor in red that's a
great two-star list of building we've
got the grade one listed church and then
we've a number of grade two buildings
around the site as well
this just shows the site location plan
and the next site sliders actually shows
this in a little bit more detail for you
here members so we've got the red line
plan of what we're actually covering
within this application and then we've
got the blue line showing the ownership
of the adjacent plot in the ownership of
the same applicant this is the redline
plan that was submitted
with the outline
so the entirety of the site was brought
forward at that point and then um
prior to this application the
ownership's been split
this is the approved indicative site
plan for the outline application and
you'll note the
the plan show t1
and t2 and this was part of the reason
for deferral previously
we've got a google street view capture
from september 2011
showing us t1 and t2 with the bungalow
that would be remaining on the site in
the foreground
and then we have
google street view from the other way so
we can have a very clear image of t1 t2
is then
hidden behind it
with regards to
the issue on on trees
the outline the dc19 application it
secured access and layout but
landscaping was reserved
so that would come forward under a under
a reserve matters application
um
both t1 and t2 have been removed from
sites
um following the grant of the outline
prior to
submission of this application
in particular i want to
just have members note the
wording of condition 4 of the outline
application which covers the time scale
for landscaping
and it is all changes in ground levels
hard landscaping planting seeding or
turping shown on the improved
landscaping detail shall be carried out
in full during the first planting and
seedling season
any trees hedges shrubs or turf
identified within the approved
landscaping details both proposed
planting and existing which die are
removed seriously damaged or seriously
diseased within a period of 10 years
from being planted or in the case of
existing planting within a period of
five years from the commencement of
development shall be replaced in the
next planting season with others of
similar size and species now
with regards to the two trees have been
removed from sight
neither are protected by tree
preservation orders and neither are we
in a conservation
area so there was no requirement for
permission from the council prior to the
removal of the trees
we've also had a
arboricultural survey submitted
it notes that one of the trees was of no
particular amenity value to the wider
area
and the other one was noted to have
ash die back
so it was already diseased
in particular members were concerned
that the removal of the trees for
prejudice the reserve matters to come
forward on the site to my mind
um
in the view of officers there is not a
there's not a requirement for the trees
shown in the indicative block plan
approved outline to be retained on the
site the detail for landscaping would
come
subsequent reserve matters application
which we've not had yet i think the
confusion for members in this instance
comes from the fact that we've applied
the landscaping condition to an outline
that doesn't give us detail of
landscaping so in effect that condition
has been placed on the outline with an
idea that when we get the landscaping
detail no conditions required on the
reserve matters because there's already
a condition
on the outline that secures the
landscaping once we've agreed it but at
this point in time
we have no landscaping otherwise agreed
however what we do need to be cognizant
of is the fact that we have a full
application here so it's not tied to
the outline planning application in any
way shape or form this is a fresh
application needs to be determined
on its merits albeit is now being
determined through the process for
appeals against non-determination
other than that numbers um the report is
as submitted last time although
notes um have been included within the
report to just note changes to
paragraphs within the mppf
um i'll pass over to members for
questions as i'm where we're
running on for time and we can run
through
any other
plans or images of the area as members
want during questions
thank you happy to open it up to
questions
to members
yep counselor
sorry to can we just
qualify i mean
um
daniel's speaking quite fast but can you
just qualify the
the um
position regarding the outline
application the conditions that were on
that that we can now no longer apply
to this one unless we make unless we
suggest new conditions for this one
could you just
confirm what those
conditions
were please yeah of course councillor so
um the outline application
um could still come forward
um it's still live we could still
receive a reserve matters application on
it um there would likely be some um
[Music]
some back and forth regarding um the
trees have been removed from the site
um but in my view the the landscaping
details would only be agreed a reserved
matters stage so
we we're still waiting for those
landscaping details for that condition
condition four to bite
against but um the other conditions are
all fairly straightforward you know we
have the
[Music]
development to be in accordance with the
indicative block plan
we have the time limit for reserve
matters to come forward and then for
commencement of the application
we have the landscaping
we have provision for the accesses
to be laid out prior to
first use of the dwelling
we have details for surface treatment we
have details for bins in collection
areas we have
details for parking
[Music]
we have some archaeological
investigation that would come forward
prior to commencement of the the
application anyway
and then we have
removal permitted development rights
from the site and we also have condition
14 which imposes a height restriction on
dwellings coming forward as part of the
reserve matters such that no dwelling
exceed one and a half stories in height
now
those conditions don't bite on
this application as a full
planning application what members might
want to consider is what conditions that
were applied at the outline
whether the fundamental underlying
planning reasons for imposing those
conditions
still come and bite on this full
planning application and you would want
to see those carried through or you'd
want to see the design of the um
proposed dwelling um be brought forward
in conjunction with those um conditions
okay yes please thank you because one of
the reasons i ask is one is the trees
that have now gone and two is the fact
that this is
the outline was for one and a half story
and this is
effectively for two next next tour
was not next door anymore but on the
site that was a bungalow um
so
are we saying that we can
put a condition saying that it's only
one and a half story
so
we have a full application before so we
have details of the design so we know
exactly how
tall it would be if i cycle forward
it's a it's a two-story design that's
come forward
what
we do have and what we have shown by
um
the agent in this instance is that the
height of the building would not exceed
six meters which is the height of the
bungalow already on on-site
and if i show you that in slightly more
detail we have the slightly darker grey
shadow of the bungalow
superimposed against
the side profile of the dwelling so we
can see we have an increase in in bulk
here but we have no overall increase in
height
and it's for that reason that
within the relevant sections of the
report officer's view is that
that is that is sufficient to see the
the spirit of that condition brought
forward and applied
to this application now with regards to
the trees we obviously cannot
roll back
um you know we can't we can't bring the
trees back on site what is within
members gift um if they want to consider
approval of the application is whether
or not they would like to see a
landscaping condition imposed and
whether or not as part of that
landscaping condition they want to make
clear their requirement for
mature trees to be included
within any landscaping that came forward
on the site
uh cancer field
just wondering the height restriction we
had it was expressed as one and a half
stories do we know whether that was
based purely on what was suggesting
there and not exceeding the height of
the bungalow or was it something more
widely about the street scene and
similar properties in the area
you know
not affecting the listed buildings etc
so with regards to
height restriction
the existing bungalow on site was to be
retained is about six meters tall which
is about commentary with a
one and one half story residential
development and i think
possibly some of the
sometimes there is an issue with
conditions that require
building heights to be limited to a
number of stories in the commercial
development two stories can often be
in excess of what we assume for a
two-story residential development but
that's sort of
to one other side so in terms of um
in terms of the height restriction i
i've in my view it's to retain
the overall height of the the run of
development on that side on the other
side of church road we've got a number
of two-story dwellings
um which are in excess of the height of
the bungalow on this side of the road
but in terms of of their impact on on
the listed building that's slightly more
reduced going to the fact that they're
not within the same sight lines the
other thing the height restriction would
do is views down church road towards the
church it would ensure that no
development then encroaches further upon
um any views you might have of the
church spire from the west of the
village
but in retaining the
in matching the height of the bungalow
we have no increase on the overall
height so we have no more restriction
on
of that view from distance than we would
have
um where we'd have a one and a half
story
dwelling post there
yeah
struggling to think whether i understand
that yes so it's not a matter of we've
now got this mission to do
beautiful buildings whatever and one and
a half stories is beautiful it's pure it
is an issue of height
compared with the bungalow and as you
saw the visibility of the church beyond
one club
okay you've got that thank you
councilman
um thank you i'm just looking at the um
the previous application on this site uh
ca i'm assuming that neither of the
other two
um bungalows that had outline permission
have got to reserve matters or any other
further further on so it was a outline
for three
um
one and a half story buildings uh and we
the other two uh are just sitting there
with outline permission
um and does
if this has changed because obviously
the access arrangement has changed
does that have any bearing on the
outline permission that's already
granted on the other two dwellings so
we'd have it would have a bearing on
plot two
in the access was determined or outlined
so you would therefore be in a position
if you need to change the outline to
make plot two able to come forward as a
reserve matters application otherwise
any reserve matters application wouldn't
be in accordance with the granted
outline and wouldn't be able to come
forward on plot two on the other side of
the bungalow we still have the access
retained as it was approved at an
outline stage which was for the bungalow
and plot one and no sorry plot three to
share the same access so plot three
could still come forward as a reserve
matters application you would just be in
a situation where
they both need to come forward
separately with plot two coming forward
following section 73 to an outline
which is slightly convoluted and and
difficult i accept but
this this is the situation we're in with
the site you know having gained outline
permission and then then being sold into
different ownerships
counter e burn you were next
um thank you chair if i just come back
about the the roof it's not so much the
roof hide it's the roof shape because
the the church is directly
this building is the first one you would
see
so when it's when it's got a
um
a less shallow
a shallow a you know
less
and the church you're looking through
that to church behind whereas if it's a
chalet bungalow with more of a um
a steeper
um
pitched roof then you will you know i'm
not saying you'll see the church
necessarily but the the the views are
are different and the the block as it
were of that building that you're seeing
is very very different having that um
less um that shallower kind of pitched
roof
so
we couldn't that's that's what i'm
asking about then whether we can
condition this to be
one and a half and not two because one
and a half tends to be a steeper pitch
and secondly the
with the trees we could only
condition trees on the
um
west and south sides of the boundary
presumably because there is no space
between the
proposed outline
on the existing plot sorry the existing
bungalow and this one
here
is that correct
so in terms of the the design of the the
roof shape
i think that's something for members to
tease out in debate if that is a reason
why
they are opposed to the application we
can tease out to form a reason for
refusal if that's where our members
find themselves
um in debate with regards to the trees
we'd only be able to
condition um land within the applicant's
ownership so that's this plot and the
neighbouring plot
thanks just as a point of information i
think there is an example of a house
with an extremely sharp pitched roof in
backton as you drive along the street
that stern
single-story one-and-a-half-story house
so you'll be careful for what you wish
for how big is a story etc but now on
the on the landscape if i think you sort
of partly answer that um it isn't down
on the recommended um issue for
conditions here but certainly i think
that's something that we would do what
sorts of things can we do is it just a
general one or an enhanced um
landscaping scheme because i do think
it's important uh in a site well in any
site actually particularly one offs like
this that it is
softened as far as possible when it
comes to the street scene so what would
you recommend please i think so i think
if members were keen to see a
landscaping condition that's something
we could reasonably impose
um
with regards to its scope
for residential development
okay yeah i suggest we do the public
speakers next and hear what they have to
say and we may get yeah see we'll see uh
counselor
yeah
yeah i i
yeah
i thought
when i read this on monday i thought i
understood it but unfortunately i've
become more confused as it has
evolved i think there's
two fundamentals i don't really
understand one is is
what is left of the outline
if we if this is approved
is is the outline incapable of
um of implementation
without without effectively making a new
full application instead
um
given that it was it was three
and we're effectively using half the
land to put one on i think and then what
is the status of slide 10 which is
interestingly headed planning queries
can we go back to the presentation
please mandy
so with regards to the outline that's
still live it's still capable of coming
forward if i
quickly flick back
so we have plot three the existing
bungalow plot two and plot one plot one
and plot two are within the ownership of
the applicant at this point
and this application
changes the approved access which was
one access to be shared for plot one and
plot two so that we'd have one single
access for plot one and a new access
created
here
what that would mean is that plot two
would be unable to come forward with a
fully compliant scheme for reserve
matters unless the council were to agree
to alter the access arrangements already
agreed in the outline through a section
73 application
plot 3
provided it shares the access with the
existing bungalow which is in place
would be able to come forward as a
reserve matters separately
there's no there's no requirement that
the reserve matters come forward
on the entirety of the site we could
deal with three individual reserve
matters to deal with each three units
where we've ended up at with is a full
application here on plot one
okay yeah yeah
i think that helped so yeah i think
a response from the the
agent to issues raised in consultation
and that's just been pulled across
verbatim in terms of its title for for
members there on slide 10.
yes
um
yes
that slide 10 planning queries is as
good as any actually
the it appears to show
a 2.4 meter high
fence that's a very high fence
facing into
effectively countryside
beyond to in a southerly direction
is there no comment
adverse to that because it seems to me
that some that's something that
landscape consultants usually frown upon
mightily
so in terms of um
fencing we've got fencing we've got
we've got fencing to the rear we've got
fencing to the side
if we quickly
try and jump back
to
so
[Music]
so we've got
so we've got existing dwellings to the
to the rear here so a slightly higher
fence
above what you'd normally be able to do
is permit development that would allow
you up to two meters it's just going to
provide additional screening
here so there's additional privacy
between
the dwellings to the rear and the
dwelling to be brought forward here
okay thank you
not not not my point my point is is that
effectively that that boundary
faces
countryside admittedly across the corner
of the garden of the the um the other
property there whatever it's called but
um
yeah i mean i can see
privacy from their point of view but
what about the wider landscape view
to a degree yes i think i think a close
boarded fence is is more
suited to residential areas and creating
that hard boundary is often
[Music]
beneficial
what we could what we could look to do
is say if we were looking to impose a
landscaping condition
look to say notwithstanding the fencing
details shown we want to have
alternative boundary treatments to
include the erection of or the planting
of two large trees
that
okay i'm going to move on to did you
really want do you want to come back
it's a very very quick point i mean
you've got to be reasonable about
fencing it's all very well saying what
it looks in the comments in debate now
no no no no no but i'm just making a
problem
you get deer or other things coming to
your garden you could be pragmatic and
reasonable
thank you okay so we're going to move on
um
so thank you for that um i'll now ask
the parish council to speak again you
have up to three minutes
thank you
again um the parish council objected the
original outline application because the
density proposed and here we see one of
the consequences of the decision
this council made
the council objects to this current
proposal i'm very surprised to find it
being recommended for approval by the
case officer whilst a full application
rather than for reserve matters we
consider the outline conditions relating
to the scale of the buildings and their
access are relevant to its consideration
the outline permission is 1.5 story
building but in reality this is a
two-story building as internally
designed to provide full height rooms
the first floor
although the ridge height is stated as
six meters achieved with the very
shallow pictures we've heard of less
than 20 degrees the alien to the setting
we have suffolk
typical suffolk roofs which have pitches
in excess of 45 and some even more as we
know
part of the rear elevation has a pent
roof which appears the flat roof with
the grey cladding
and a large area of paving to the front
the building has an industrial and urban
appearance out of keeping with any other
properties in the vicinity
proposed building is much wider than
that originally visited outline butting
up to the east and west boundaries
cramping the relationship the adjacent
plot this crowding would give the effect
of a tightly packed row of houses once
the others are constructed it's wholly
inappropriate in a rural setting
next open farmland where significant
mature trees have been removed from the
boundary and the first house on that
side of church road directly in the line
of sight towards the grade one church
and mary the virgin when viewed from the
west
in the previous item on your agenda we
heard the efforts that that applicant
has made to recognize the local
vernacular in the design of their
dwellings and they are well set back
from the road what a contrast to this
proposal
when you look at the elevation which
presents itself to the west the gable
end has a profile quite out of keeping
with those elsewhere on church road have
a significant detrimental effect on this
important visual aspect of the historic
heart of bacter it may be many decades
before any tree planting if any land
remains on this plot to do that planting
would achieve any screening in respect
of the access to add an extra entry
point for this dwelling rather than the
shared opening of the church road has
agreed outline
the site compounds a pre-existing
problem with the site although in a 30
mile an hour zone this is sadly ignored
church road is very busy especially at
school times and visibility displays
will be compromised by parked cars which
use every inch of available curbside
parking environmentally the site is
prone to flooding as evidenced over a
number of weeks this winter this will
only worsen when the drainage system for
development you just discussed overflows
into the ditch which terminates the
boundary of this property the parish
council urged the committee to recommend
refusal this application on the grounds
of its design being out of character
with the rest of church road and it's
compounding the over development of this
site thank you
thanks very much any questions at all
nope okay well thank you very much um we
do not have an objector we don't have a
supporter or the agent so i'll move
straight to the ward member
council melon over to you thank you
chair um
i first prepared this little speech back
in april when this came to um committee
b i'm not quite sure why it's come back
to committee a but um
so my speech starts thank you madam
chair but
obviously that's wrong
um i'd like to take a few minutes of the
committee's time to explain in detail
why i've called this application in in
and why i would like to see it refused
we talked with the last application
about how bacten is a key service center
and this is very close to the site of
the last application so
i would i would just echo what i said
earlier about the sustainability of it
and close to services
the original application on this site
was for four dwellings and that was
refused
and then a subsequent application for
three dwellings an outline application
was
agreed and conditions were applied to
deal with highway concerns and also
objections from our heritage team
so the highways had originally wanted
only one access point to serve all four
properties
that's existing bungalow and the three
new
they eventually accepted two shared
accesses
each serving two dwellings and i'll
return to this point later
now the heritage officer was very
concerned about the impact of the
development on the important view of the
grade one listed at mary's church and
objected to the outline application but
he did say
harm could be avoided at reserve matters
stage if the new dwellings were single
story only and appropriate external
facing materials were proposed
and in fact the outline permission was
granted with the condition that the new
dwelling should be limited to one and a
half stories
it's also interesting to note that the
planning statement accompanying the
application identified two significant
trees and a natural hedge at the front
of the property all of which are gone
now what we expected to see in due
course were one or
more reserve matters applications coming
along as the plots were sold
but what we what we have before us today
is not a reserve matters application
it's a full planning application and as
such it does not sit within the
parameters and i think the very
reasonable parameters of the outlying
conditions
it seeks to overturn them to ignore them
to set them aside
however the outline permission remains
a significant material consideration and
as far as i understand it this would
make the other
outline null and void and each of the
other applications would have to come
through as full applications
so let me talk about road safety
this location is important because of
its proximity to bacton primary school
at beginning and the end of the school
day church road becomes filled with cars
parents park along this frontage to drop
off or to pick up their children and
i've done the same myself when my
children were at that primary school
now increasing the number of accesses
the number of drop curves
means more places where vehicles are
crossing the pavement to get on or off
the road
highways originally wanted a single
entrance but accepted two shared
entrances but this application wants to
make that three and i guess it would be
eventually four when they're all built
out
looking at the layout is just about
possible for two cars to maneuver and be
able to enter or exit this site in
forward gear which is very important in
this location with the school traffic
however the plans show that this house
is effectively a four bedroom dwelling
and the suffolk parking standards
require three off-road spaces
for a four bed dwelling and there's not
space for here for three vehicles and
therefore
there would be a safety implication they
wouldn't be able to get onto the road in
forward gear
can i move on to the setting of the
grade one listed mary's church as you
travel along church road in an easterly
direction
to the left you have the manor house
mr mr chambers lives to the right you
have agricultural fields
then approaching taylor's green the
tower of saint mary's church comes into
view
now this proposed dwelling would appear
immediately under the bell tower as you
travel towards the church it will be the
first house on that side of the road it
won't be shielded by any trees because
they've gone
this is the view that the heritage
officer is referring to and this is why
he sought something smaller in scale and
with appropriate materials
but this application is for a two-story
dwelling with a very low pitch roof
and with a striking modern design here i
think it would be in congress it bears
no resemblance to any other house
in the vicinity and i refer you to the
mppf
where it says that we we should ensure
that developments a will add to the
overall quality of the area b are
visually interactive as a result of good
architecture and c are sympathetic to
local character well it seems to me this
application
doesn't
meet any of those three
no so i have no objection to a modern
design and to the use of grey cladding
and we have examples of that in backton
but not here
this location is a sensitive one and the
heritage officer has identified that
and there's a scope for a more
appropriate design which would fit
with the surrounding buildings
if i could just touch on other matters
briefly the size of the pro's proposed
building is much larger than that shown
on the outline permission it fills the
plot and it looks like over development
the windows of the second floor
on the second floor height there's
concern about overlooking with the
neighbours
uh loss of residential immunity there
there are issues of drainage here this
site was a wash with standing water for
much of last winter
and lastly as this application with two
trees mentioned previously
and that they are now gone very very
disappointing so i asked this the
committee to refuse this application
it's contrary to the mppf it's two-story
rather than 1.5
as as in the conditions the design is
not in keeping with local architecture
and it has a significant impact on
mary's church
i think the community and and its
representatives do accept the principle
of development on this site but we want
to see a good appropriate design
which this is not
thank you
any questions for the ward member
no okay so us to discuss debate and come
to a conclusion councilor madison and
councillor
yesterday i i i
i'm glad that councillor melinda got his
head around it all it's
unsurprisingly um so much more than i
had
um as to understand it all and i i think
we should send him into bat at the the
appeal for non-determination frankly
because
he'll make a cracking good job of it
um
yeah i i just agree with him really um
you know there's just a sequence of of
things making it worse
was worse than it needed to have been at
the outset of um
of of this
outline site as a whole
i can't support
approval of
it okay next was castle eben
um thank you very much chair um
i
i know this area very well i am
um this is the
affected as you're going through bacton
this property will be the first one you
would see immediately for the church
and the church is surrounded by it's got
huge trees it's a beautiful location
and
i believe the
this design and approach to this
building here would
detrimentally affect that view beyond
repair as it were
there are
many concerns i know the again the the
school drop-offs the
the
parents queue on that road
further south from where this
development is so
you know
it would be very hazardous coming in and
out of that driveway and you know as
has been said when it has was previously
a driveway serving a couple of
properties that was a different matter
this will be just you can
it just won't be viable really
um
i think there's an issue with
i'm concerned about the fact that these
trees have been taken down at this point
and that um no concern
considerations made that particularly
again with the fact that the trees
surround the church and it's that
particular area that is
is um
very
um
reminiscent of a particular
local amenity with particular
characteristics that have sat around
that village church and the houses on
the other side of the road
in terms of their age as well
personally i would like to propose
refusal
on the basis of design highways heritage
landscaping
development not reflecting local
characteristics not protecting
residential amenity
et cetera et cetera
and i i just think it's over development
it's the
if they were putting a bungalow that was
a similar size or to the existing one
and of um
sort of relative appearance of the trees
have been left there it would be a
different matter but it's it it isn't so
i would propose refusal thank you chair
thank you very much uh next up is
councillor password and councillor
matson um thank you very much matthew
yeah i am i'm in agreement with with
rachel on this i don't think that this
is compatible with the street scene i
think it's insensitive to the setting of
the grade one listed building and you
know
i'm sure many of us have you come if
you're easterly bound along church right
in backton there are some really
interesting individual houses there and
so on it is a nice streak to come along
i'm not trying anyway trying to be
presumptive about this but i do think
this is likely to stick out as a sore
thumb we're dealing with the one
application i absolutely understand that
but nevertheless if we were to agree
that which to me looks like a 1960s
um estate house that you find all over
places like ipswich and i don't think
it's appropriate in this setting i think
we've heard from andrew and the parish
council they're not opposed to
development but for heaven's sake
looking at our grade one beautiful
churches here in the in mid-suffolk
let's make sure that the setting is
right i completely understand why the
officers have recommended um
granting permission i happen to disagree
on the nuance of particularly on the
design i don't think it's compatible so
i'm very happy to support rejection on
that and if you want a second i'll jump
in there now before anyone else thank
you councillor manson
uh thank you chair uh much of all i was
gonna say uh has already been said by
councillor e burnham and i too was happy
to second her proposal um on all those
grounds um
and i think uh although uh we've talked
a bit about massing and volume
and yes in a previous application today
and yes okay so the ridge height is the
same as the existing bungalow but
because of the shallower eaves
we've actually effectively got
triangular prisms stuck on the side of
quite a large chunky sort of design and
i think the massing of this building is
inappropriate for its setting and that's
what makes it not fit in
with the
existing bungalow that's in the middle
of the site uh
and yes in in a way those
i've got the image of back to church up
on google street view on my screen now
and actually the the pleasant slope of
the existing bungalow acts as a sort of
frame uh for that church tower as you
come along that road and i think having
these stuck on um
shallow roof um two-story building
will look completely out of place so so
i am
in support of the current um proposal uh
for refusal
can i just ask the case officers if they
uh because obviously we've had it
proposed in second we've been given uh
several well quite a few reasons by
councillor ebern have you got enough to
put together uh wording on refusal
i think i'm nearly i just probably need
to check a couple of points so we're
particularly thinking about massing the
ball
bulk
um
the roof pitch and eaves
and the width of the proposed dwelling
does that
encompass the
particular problem
seeing nods
okay uh and then in terms of the impact
that has i'm suggesting that you're
picking up on the character and
appearance of the locality
including listed buildings um
and then separately i would suggest
bearing one the points about heritage
that i think i'm i think i'm there just
about there on two reasons that that
massing and bulk would also have a low
level of less than substantial harm uh
particularly to the designated heritage
asset which is grade one saint mary's
thank you um and that it would
impose itself on those views um
an obscure part of the church and that
there wouldn't be public benefits to
outweigh that level of harm
is does that
okay if i might need just another
miniature just just to finalize that
okay so possibly another reason on
landscape
uh just to say if we are going to look
at a reason for reviews on landscape um
i think it needs to be framed around the
existing landscape that will be created
by this application
not the fact that we would like to see
the trees returned
um the the other thing for members to
consider is do they want to
delegate authority to officers in this
instance to refuse the application for
the reasons that
gemma has set out
i'll let the officers finish first and
i'll add it for some people necessary
so we've we've got we've got the appeal
for non-determination so the
recommendation
in the report is not valid and the
determination that members give will be
passed and defended appeal in front of
the inspectorate um
what i am conscious of is that
we have um
the the areas we want to look at in
terms of reasons for refusal
um
our members happy that they have
got a a direction so they would in
effect give a minded to decision to
officers to say we are minded to refuse
on
and we delegate authority to officers to
draft the reasons for refusal to be
you know throwing the whole kitchen sink
at
refusals and so on but it's a bit
different with this with this um
with this non-determination of penis on
but i was particularly struck by it by
what councilman said about the um
the the the school safety accesses and
it started off as a deal that was going
to be
effectively for
including the existing one with one
access and we're heading towards three
access points
and um and that's quite a safety issue
and safety's actually been bumped up the
agenda quite a long way in the mppf
pedestrian safety in particular
i think
i mean
our view versus highways view yeah
exactly that's what i'm just wondering
i think
the npv is still on severe harm and i
i absolutely appreciate what you're
saying in the schools is one more
driveway taking us over that point in a
30 mile an hour zone
i'm not sure
that that would be something that would
stand i think it might be a kitchen
sinks yeah yeah not happy too
and councillor phil do you want to come
in yes i was going to point out
i agree that um
the severe harm is actually not the
safety condition that's the impact on
the highways capacity isn't it
it's an unacceptable
impact on safety but
i think we've got to be careful about
winding that up too much because
it could clearly be that we could grant
permission for this one house and then
refuse the the next one which will have
lost its access and
highways could well say they don't want
that number of accesses on the road for
safe safety reasons so you could
actually go
commit one um and get rid of two others
so i think we've got to be careful about
overplaying that
cause okay but the the point about the
uh the impact on the view of the church
the difference with the street scene it
seemed to me to be very significant and
i suppose a personal hang up as well is
that that uh
close boarded fence
as the first element you see as you
enter the the village is also
something which is hardly rural
so i think on that basis we've got a
minded to refusal and we understand the
reasons why we've been guided down that
route and that makes sense to us all and
it has been proposed by council eben
seconded by councillor passmore
um for reminded to refusal with
delegation to officers
uh for the reasons do we need to go
through the reasons yeah and gemma do
you just want to run through them for us
yeah
i think i'm there then so yeah i'm
minded to refuse uh on the following in
order to defend the appearance of
non-determination
the massing and bulk of the proposal
with particular regards to the roof
pitch and eaves and the width of the
proposed dwelling would have a
detrimental impact on the character and
appearance of the locality failing to
respond to the character of the site and
relationship to surroundings and
locality including listed buildings
the proposal would also have an
incongruous impact on the character of
the locality as a result of the close
boarded fencing in this location
as such the proposal
would be
contrary to local plan policy h13 and
hb1 and policy cs5 for the core strategy
and paragraph 130 of the mppf
second reason the massing and bulk of
the proposal with regards to the roof
pitch and width is assessed to lead to a
low level of less than substantial harm
to a designated heritage asset
identified as being the grade one listed
saint mary's church
it would impose itself on views of the
designated heritage asset obscuring part
of the church and its tower when viewed
from the west without public benefits to
outweigh this home as such the proposal
would be contrary to local plan policy
hb1 paragraph 202 of the mppf as well as
section 661 of the town and country
planning listed building conservation
act of 1990
council rebound council passed are you
happy with that
yeah good okay let's take a vote on that
basis
thank you chair so i have i don't think
all that text will fit in
so i put the members are minded to
refuse application number dc2005572
for the reasons as read out by the area
planning manager
for the final time that vote is now in
progress
i'm waiting for
councillor field
i can take your vote verbally if it's
easier
thank you that's six votes for chair
okay well thank you very much so that's
uh refused so members can i just thank
everyone seriously because we have put
in a long day today and it's been really
everyone's engaged a lot throughout the
whole process and we've given each
application the time it needs
the only other gender item is gender
item nine site inspections do we need to
report any site inspections yes we do
they'll clearly be one next wednesday
following a decision earlier today and
officers will be in touch in due course
so can i thank everyone and we formally
closed the meeting at one minute past
six
you